los Globos se utilizaron por primera vez
para la vigilancia militar durante Las
Guerras revolucionarias francesas en el
siglo XIX Entonces por qué china
elegiría utilizar uno hoy en día los
Globos son más baratos de lanzar que los
satélites más fáciles de recuperar y el
movimiento de un satélite está
restringido a su trayectoria orbital
aunque los expertos dicen que la menor
velocidad del globo permite un tipo
diferente de vigilancia
pueden permanecer allí durante días en
realidad pueden obtener una cobertura
mejor hasta cierto punto mejor y más
amplia que la que pueden obtener sus
satélites espías y también pueden
comprobar Cómo va a reaccionar Estados
Unidos ante futuras provocaciones ante
cualquier tipo de incursiones
adicionales pueden calibrar nuestras
reparación militar
mientras que los drones están limitados
a un máximo de 18 kilómetros de altitud
los Globos pueden volar más de 20
kilómetros de altura muy por encima del
tráfico aéreo son silenciosos de bajas
emisiones y prácticamente indetectables
los instrumentos de vigilancia
instalados funcionan con paneles solares
pueden controlarse distancia o moverse
con el viento y utilizan nuevos
algoritmos Para aprovechar la
meteorología en realidad hay algo que es
muy nuevo que es la adición de estos
algoritmos de aprendizaje automático que
pueden ajustar la altitud del globo para
captar el viento Así es como se controla
su trayectoria Estados Unidos no es
ajeno a los globos según político el
pentágono ha gastado 3,8 millones de
dólares en proyectos con globos en los
últimos dos años y tiene asignados unos
27 millones más para continuar con estos
esfuerzos